last night joe biden delivered his first
speech to a joint
session of congress the senate coming
over to the house of representatives to
hear joe biden deliver this speech
not called the state of the union it's
typically not called the state of the
union when it's a president's first year
in office but it is essentially a state
of the union and joe biden
did lay out his plan for a 1.8 trillion
dollar
spending package including funding paid
leave community college
and all of the things we previewed in
some detail yesterday so i won't redo
the policy proposal nitty gritty again
but it was overall
a very policy heavy speech this could
not have been more different from
recent state of the union addresses from
donald trump which contained
almost no policy but trump aside
even compared to barack obama compared
to george w bush before him
it was really just a focus on policy
with very little vapid political
rhetoric now that's not necessarily good
or bad
vapid political rhetoric can be a good
thing if it's inspirational or
coalesces people or it can be nonsense
or whatever
but this was really a focus on policy a
focus on vaccination
even ted cruz here applauding after joe
biden
announces 220 million vaccine doses in a
hundred days
and urges everybody to get themselves
vaccinated
right now right away go get
vaccinated america go and get the
vaccination
they're available
you're eligible now
joe biden talking about those
vaccination numbers but also talking
a lot about job creation
all this was all going on the economy
created
more than one million three hundred
thousand new jobs in a hundred days
more jobs with first
more jobs in the first hundred days than
any
president on record the international
monetary fund
international now of course that is
true context does matter
we were and are in a recovery period
from an externally motivated job loss
caused by the pandemic
now many of those jobs are coming back
you expect
any president to brag about job growth
whether or not they had a hand in it it
is still a good thing but it is
important to understand the context
many of these jobs would be coming back
regardless of who was president i'd
rather it be joe biden than donald trump
for sure
joe biden then jumping right into
talking about the economy and talking
about
the importance of unions much to bernie
sanders delight
and unions built the middle class
that's why i'm calling on congress
to pass protect the right to organize
act the pro act and send it to my desk
so we can support
the right to unionize
and by the way and joe biden then
much to the pleasure of most democrats
in the crowd but not mitt romney
and lauren beaubert and others saying
let's raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour
let's raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars
no one
no one working 40 hours a week
no one working 40 hours a week should
live below the poverty line
we need to ensure greater equity and
opportunity for women and while we're
doing this let's get the paycheck
fairness act to my desk as well
equal pay they spent much too long
and if you wonder whether it's too long
look behind me
joe biden also laying out how he will
pay for
much of these ideas saying the rich will
pay and mitt romney didn't seem
particularly thrilled with that either
time for corporate america
and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share
[Music]
sometimes i have arguments with my
friends in the democratic party
i think you should be able to become a
billionaire and a millionaire but pay
your fair share and on economics a
moment
that many people liked which got a lot
of attention
joe biden saying straight up trickle
down
economics has never worked
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
and it's time to grow the economy from
the bottom in the middle out
you know now i love this because
i already planned later today to talk
about
joe biden and biodynamics as they are
being called
as the antithesis to reaganomics
that line trickle-down economics has
never worked
is actually part of it saying it as
directly as anybody can and we're going
to come back to that in more detail
on foreign policy joe biden pointing out
that
he's just getting out of afghanistan
something that republicans
loved when it was trump who announced it
trump failed to do it
joe biden is doing it and republicans
are no longer clapping about it
stern deterrence and american leadership
means ending the forever war in
afghanistan
we have
we have without hyperbole the greatest
fighting force in history of the world
i'm the first president of 40 years and
knows what it means to have a son
serving in a war zone today we have
service members serving in the same war
zone as their parents did
we have service members in afghanistan
who are not yet born
on 9 11. the war in afghanistan as we
remember the debates here
were never meant to be
multi-generational undertakings
of nation building of course it was
never really about
just getting out of afghanistan it was
can we cheer for something trump is
doing
biden now is actually going to do the
thing we cheered trump for announcing
but we don't cheer anymore
because we are merely political
hypocrites real quick here is senator
ted cruz
sleeping during the speech he looked
very very sleepy apparently dreaming of
cancun
and joe biden ultimately closing out
his speech take a listen to that it's
never
ever ever been a good bet to bet against
america
and it still isn't we're the united
states of america
there's not a single thing nothing
nothing beyond our capacity
we can do whatever we set our mind to if
we do it together
so let's begin to get together
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you for your patience
some of the people in the camp of biden
is a weakling and he's old and senile
and demented we're expecting a very
short speech
and a very incoherent speech biden going
much longer than recent presidents have
during their first joint addresses to
congress
and very coherent i thought it was a
well-written speech
i thought it was about the right
duration i often think things are too
long i think it was about the right
duration
and now actually comes the tough part
which is joe biden has laid out a
variety of different policy ideas
can joe biden get any of what he
proposed
done and that is certainly easier said
than done when not only do you have
zero republican support in the house and
senate for
anything you want to do but it's not
even clear you have the support of all
of the democrats in the senate either
and we will talk about that as these
proposals become more formalized and
start to be debated
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covid rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still
open to stay afloat but covet rescue
fund is one of the few organizations
working to help
businesses reopen who have had to close
covet rescue fund crowdsources funds to
provide
grants up to one hundred thousand
dollars for these owners to create
new businesses i would implore anyone in
my audience to help covet rescue fund
in their mission by donating at
covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses
as we can the link is right underneath
this video